[Music]
ballet empowers me in a way that it
gives me confidence like to be
expressive and to be who i want to be
not who i'm expected to be
my name is mashat sachani and i'm a
pilot dancer
i started dancing when i was 9 years old
and then i've been doing it until right
now which i am 20 years old
mastering ballet is the most difficult
thing ever because it takes a lot from a
person you need to put 100 of your heart
and soul into what you're doing
i grew up in alexandra township which is
close to joburg
growing up in a township it's very scary
most of the time because you get fights
and it's like a ghetto place in a way
depending on how you look at it
life growing up was a bit challenging
because as a guy who wants to do better
you get teased a lot you know you
actually develop a thicker skin and take
it as it comes
most of my friends they have that
perception for valet being for girls
only so as a guy you have to fight that
stereotype
value is crucial for me in terms of
giving me discipline it has changed me
in a way of me being a better person and
knowing what my goals are and actually
working to achieve them
it felt amazing when i got accepted by
germic berlin and to actually get a
notification saying that you have been
accepted into our program was actually
the happiest day for me
my dream at the moment would be for me
to become a soloist and actually improve
my technique i'm still learning and
there's so much to learn
[Music]
i feel that ballet is a beautiful way of
self-expression because it allows you to
express yourself in a way that's not
verbally is actually breathtaking
i think ballet has the power to change
people's lives because it represents an
illusion where people can really find
places of comfort and escape to
from their everyday lives
[Music]
pop quiz who is this
[Music]
if you answered olympic gold medalist
freestyle skier johnny mosley
you are correct it is johnny mosley hey
i'm johnny mosley here's another
question
what exactly is johnny mosley doing
right now it's
strange it's as if johnny is figure
skating on skis
what you are witnessing is a rare
glimpse of a lost athletic art that was
once the pinnacle of freestyle skiing it
had judges it had costumes it had fans
it had a name
ski ballet
in the beginning young freestyle skiers
didn't just want to ski down they wanted
to ski fun
and they invented a new sport that would
eventually make it all the way to the
olympic games
ski ballet was born yeah just look like
a bunch of crazy stuff on skis
this is three-time world champion skier
bob howard a legend in ski valet when
the sport was in his 1980s heyday what
they didn't know then you don't know now
ski ballet is very difficult i'd like to
demonstrate when these are shot so i
brought in johnny mosley i'm johnny
mosely they know
ski ballet was a form of freestyle
skiing and it had a couple different
corporations it had pull flips
[Music]
spins linking tricks we put it all
together with rock and roll music
early on we did some moves that were
basically flex tricks where you go off
your tips and what it is is you flex
your tip up and you spin around
those are pretty difficult because
you're balancing and you can hurt
yourself real quickly you can dislocate
your knee in an instant
here's johnny doing a 720 which is two
times around we copied this from ice
skating and then he even goes to a
higher level where he goes to a 900
which means he spins around two times
lands backwards
[Applause]
the lights and ski ballet were never
brighter than when there was a
demonstration sport in the olympics in
1988 and 1992 but ski ballet was not
long for this world the spotlight dimmed
when the games dropped it in 1994 and
the whole sport went fully dark not long
after
the dna of ski ballet is actually in
everything that freestyle is today all
the spins and moves you see in the slope
style and the big air we did all that
from the very beginning that's why i
teach my students ski ballet moves i'm
going to do
i come in stock and
so the next time you're on a chairlift
and you spy johnny mosley down below
clad in a retro onesie and painting a
ski masterpiece on a canvas of virgin
snow take a moment to realize that
you're glimpsing
the flight of a phoenix
a phoenix
called ski ballet
[Music]
[Music]
people say that like oh like we're doing
this because black girls can do ballet
so this is the alternative
it has nothing to do with it i will tell
you every girl in this studio is
classically trained
everyone does ballet and everything else
[Applause]
[Music]
my name is april wilson and i'm a hip
blade dancer hitler is a mixture of hip
hop and ballet but really anything that
we can try to put on point that has like
a groovy feeling to it
my name is homer heinz bryant and i'm
the founder of hiplay and the founder
and director of the chicago
multicultural dance center i think some
people get mad when we they see us doing
hip play
it's not traditional classical ballet
we're ruining ballet well no it's not
ballet it's hip play it's how we empower
our kids it's how we empower the world
hip lane is so freeing and so open
there's a different culture here
some of the hitler movements are the hip
blitz strut the twist in and out
the moonwalk
the vivian
and the zippy
you have to have a certain posture when
you're doing ballet usually you're up
tall like straight figure posture
everything point shoes were designed for
ballet hip play is different a hip blade
you can break that you can just really
move your torso more and you can bounce
with it you know you can have fun with
it
i grew up thinking that i couldn't do
ballet because of the color of my skin
at my old studio because i was
african-american i was often overlooked
until i came to cmdc is when i really
learned that there was something off
i'm grateful to mr homer because he
showed me that i can do anything
i love dancing hiplat it just gives you
a sort of confidence and just a freedom
of just to be yourself this is the dance
genre that does not discriminate if you
have rhythm and you can group one point
you got it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
my way of expressing myself has always
been physical my mom told me like since
i was little it's like if i would be
angry or happy or whatever you would see
it in in my body language for me having
a new way of challenging my body a new
way of pushing the limits of my what my
body can do that was the
the thing that really got me hooked in
flying
my name is inga tito and i'm a dancer
and a world champion indoor skydiver
i started dancing when i was three years
old and as long as i remember i've been
dancing
when indoor skydiving came along
i found something for the first time
that i was more passionate about than i
ever was about dancing suddenly i
realized like i've just found a new way
of dancing is just on a different kind
of dance floor
the discipline that i compete in is
called freestyle but when i'm speaking
about my flying overall i prefer to use
the term air dancing
because it's not just about competing in
that set discipline it's about creating
something new and exploring the limits
of what we can do
in flying
and i would like to take flying from
being a sport
towards being a form of performing arts
flying for sure is way harder than it
looks like the wind speeds can go up to
180 miles an hour you have to be strong
you have to be flexible
a lot of the body positions look easy
but they actually require a lot to
perform them nicely so a split for
example
it might look like i'm just resting in
in that flexible body position but i'm
actually all the time pushing against
the airflow to have control
[Music]
i don't always like the use of the word
talented because it makes it sound like
only if you have that talent before you
even start flying you're gonna get good
i've always been like a hard worker
myself so if i really want to get good
at something i'm going to do whatever it
takes it just depends on how much you
want it
[Music]
you